DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY OR
THE FBI.
>> ALL RIGHT, OMAR, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
JOINING US TO DISCUSS IS
REPUBLICAN SENATOR PAT TOOMEY OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
HE'S A LEAD NEGOTIATOR IN THIS
BIPARTISAN TALKS.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THESE
NEGOTIATIONS.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT THERE'S GOING
TO BE A DEAL?
CAN YOU GIVE US AN IDEA OF THE
MEASURES YOU'RE DISCUSSING?
>> THERE'S NOT MUCH REALLY THAT
I CAN TELL YOU AT THIS POINT
EXCEPT TO SAY WE ARE MAKING
PROGRESS.
YOU HAVE MEN AND WOMEN FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE WHO ARE
NEGOTIATING IN GOOD FAITH.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT
ARE ON THE TABLE.
I THINK THE ODDS MODESTLY FAVOR
US GETTING SOMETHING DONE AND
ACTUALLY THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
IN TEN YEARS I HAVE FELT THAT
WAY.
SO YEAH, I'M CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC.
>> REPUBLICAN SENATORS WHO WERE
INSIDE THE ROOM DURING YOUR
PARTY LUNCH TODAY SAY THAT SOME
OF YOUR COLLEAGUES FEEL THAT THE
CURRENT DEAL MIGHT GO TOO FAR.
THEY'RE PREDICTING AT LEAST HALF
OF THE REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE
WOULD VOTE AGAINST IT.
THAT IS STILL THEORETICALLY 75
VOTES TO PASS IT.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE
CRITICS?
ARE YOU CONFIDENT YOU CAN GET
ENOUGH REPUBLICAN VOTES TO PASS,
AT LEAST TEN?
>> JAKE, I WOULD SAY IT'S WAY
TOO SOON TO BE TRYING TO
SPECULATE ABOUT VOTE COUNTS.
I MEAN, WE HAVEN'T NAILED DOWN
WHAT'S GOING TO BE IN AND WHAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE IN.
AND THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE OF THE
IDEAS THAT ARE GOING TO BE IN.
THE LANGUAGE MATTERS ENORMOUSLY.
SO CERTAINLY MY HOPE WOULD BE A
MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS WOULD BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS.
THAT WOULD BE VERY MUCH WHERE I
HOPE WE WOULD END UP, BUT I
THINK IT'S TOO SOON TO KNOW.
>> SENATOR RICK SCOTT WHEN HE
WAS GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT OF
FLORIDA, SIGNED INTO LAW PRETTY
SWEEPER MEASURES AFTER THE
PARKLAND MASSACRE IN 2018, WHICH
INCLUDED RED FLAG LAWS, WHICH I
UNDERSTAND SOME OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES ARE PUBLICLY VOICING
CONCERN ABOUT IN TERMS OF THEM
NOT PROVIDING DUE PROCESS AND
THE LIKE.
OUR CORRESPONDENT LEYLA SANTIAGO
TOOK A LOOK AT THE RED FLAG LAWS
AND HOW THEY'RE WORKING IN
FLORIDA.
EVEN CONSERVATIVE SHERIFFS SAY
THEY'RE WORKING WELL.
IS RICK SCOTT AT ALL TALKING AT
ALL ABOUT HOW THAT REFORM HE
SIGNED INTO LAW IS WORKING?
>> I HAVEN'T HAD THAT
CONVERSATION WITH SENATOR SCOTT,
SO I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT HIS
VIEW IS OF THE IMPLEMENTATION.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS.
I THINK IT'S UNLIKELY THAT THERE
WOULD BE A NATIONAL RED FLAG
LAW, PER SE, BUT WHAT MIGHT FIND
ITS WAY INTO THIS PACKAGE, WHAT
IS UNDER CONSIDERATION, IS
PROVIDING SOME FEDERAL
INCENTIVES AND RESOURCES TO
ENCOURAGE STATES TO ENACT THEIR
OWN RED FLAG LAWS, PROVIDED THAT
THEY PROVIDE SOME DUE PROCESS,
BECAUSE AFTER ALL, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT DEPRIVING A PERSON
OF A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT PRIOR
TO THEM HAVING ACTUALLY DONE
SOMETHING WRONG.
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT HOW
YOU DO THAT.
BUT THAT SAID, I DO THINK THERE
ARE CASES WHERE RED FLAG LAWS
CAN WORK AND THAT'S PART OF THE
DISCUSSION.
>> A SOURCE TELLS CNN THAT
SENATE MINORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL HAS PRIVATELY
EXPRESSED AN OPENNESS FOR
RAISING THE AGE FROM 18 TO 21
FOR THE ABILITY TO PURCHASE
SEMIAUTOMATIC RIFLES.
HE HAS NOT SAID THAT PUBLICLY.
IT DOESN'T SEEM AS THAT'S PART
OF YOUR FINAL DEAL.
IT WASN'T WHEN I TALKED TO CHRIS
MURPHY WITH WHOM YOU HAVE BEEN
DEALING, THE DEMOCRAT, ON SUNDAY
HE DID NOT MENTION IT.
IT DOES SEEM A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS OPPOSE IT.
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM OTHER
REPUBLICANS WHO MIGHT SUPPORT
STRONGER MEASURES IN PRIVATE BUT
WON'T DO SO PUBLICLY FOR
WHATEVER REASON?
>> NO, I HAVE NOT HAD THAT
CONVERSATION WITH ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES, NOT WITH SENATOR
McCONNELL, NOT WITH OTHERS.
LOOK, I THINK THAT IT IS WORTH
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING PROVIDING
SOME EXTRA SCRUTINY FOR YOUNG
PURCHASERS.
BUT PROHIBITIONS ARE -- THAT
WOULD BE VERY TOUGH.
>> SO POSSIBLY A WAITING PERIOD
FOR SOMEBODY 18 TO 21, POSSIBLY
TIME TO GO THROUGH AND MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ISN'T A JUVENILE
RECORD THAT'S BLINKING RED?
>> WELL, I DON'T WANT TO GET TOO
DEEP INTO THE SPECIFICS, JAKE,
BECAUSE THESE ARE MOVING TARGETS
AND ONGOING DISCUSSIONS, BUT
HEIGHTENED LEVEL OF SCRUTINY
MIGHT MAKE SENSE CONSIDERING
THAT SO MANY OF THESE MASSACRES
ARE COMMITTED BY YOUNG ADULTS,
GUYS IN THEIR LATE TEENS OR
EARLY 20s, WHO HAVE A HISTORY OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
SO IT SORT OF STANDS TO REASON
YOU WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A BETTER
WAY TO UNDERSTAND THAT BEFORE
SOMEONE WALKS AWAY WITH A
FIREARM.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN VERY ACTIVE FOR
YEARS NOW, ESPECIALLY AFTER THE
SANDY HOOK MASSACRE, WORKING
WITH ANOTHER FELLOW NRA ENDORSED
SENATOR, JOE MANCHIN, TRYING TO
EXPAND BACKGROUND CHECKS TO
INCLUDE THOSE PRIVATE SALES AT
GUN SHOWS.
I'M SORRY, THE ONES THAT
AREN'T -- THE ONES THAT AREN'T
DONE BY GUN STORES BUT ARE
RATHER JUST PERSON-TO-PERSON.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE IN THIS
FINAL PACKAGE.
WHY NOT?
WHY ARE YOUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES BALKING ON THAT?
>> SO, LET'S BE CAREFUL.
SO THE MANCHIN SLASH TOOMEY
APPROACH WAS NOT INTENDED TO
CAPTURE A PRIVATE TRANSACTION
BETWEEN MYSELF AND MY NEXT DOOR
NEIGHBOR, FOR INSTANCE.
BUT WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO
CAPTURE AND WHAT I STILL THINK
WE SHOULD CAPTURE ARE WHAT WE
CONSIDER COMMERCIAL SALES.
AND I THINK AT GUN SHOWS, YOU
HAVE A LEVEL OF ACTIVITY THAT
REALLY CONSTITUTES COMMERCIAL
SALES.
I THINK WHEN TRANSACTIONS ARE
ADVERTISED AND ESPECIALLY
ADVERTISED OVER THE INTERNET,
THAT AMOUNTS TO A COMMERCIAL
ACTIVITY.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE BACKGROUND
CHECKS ON ALL COMMERCIAL SALES.
I DON'T THINK THE MANCHIN/TOOMEY
VERSION OF THAT IS GOING TO BE
IN A FINAL PACKAGE HERE.
BUT I WOULD SUGGEST THERE ARE
MANY WAYS THAT YOU COULD
ACCOMPLISH THAT GOAL OF INSURING
THAT YOU CAPTURE A LOT MORE
TRANSACTIONS AND HAVE THAT
BACKGROUND CHECK OCCUR.
SO LET'S WAIT AND SEE WHAT
FINALLY EMERGES.
I AM HOPING THAT WE WILL EXPAND
BACKGROUND CHECKS IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY.
>> THE EMOTIONAL TESTIMONY WE
HEARD TODAY BEFORE THE HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE FROM VICTIMS
OF GUN VIOLENCE, DOES THAT HAVE
ANY IMPACT ON YOUR FELLOW
REPUBLICAN SENATORS?
>> I DON'T KNOW, JAKE.
HONESTLY, YOU KNOW, MOST
SENATORS HAVE SCHEDULES THAT IS
COMPLETELY BOOKED NONSTOP ALL
DAY LONG.
AND VERY FEW OF US, IS MY GUESS,
HAVE HAD TIME TO WATCH A HOUSE
HEARING, BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT
IT WAS SO EMOTIONALLY POWERFUL.
MY GUESS IS IT WILL BE REPLAYED
MANY TIMES ON MANY SHOWS.
SO OVER TIME, PEOPLE WILL SEE
IT.
IT'S VERY HARD TO SAY WHAT